[inaudible]
here's a friend of mine, she doesn't talk a lot,
but when she does it's usually about something interesting.
So you better pay attention.
This kind of suspicious character over here is listening in.
Now he can make out what she's saying and he gets it.
And when she notices this lurker and turns around to chastise him,
he knows exactly what she's saying. Freeze.
This is an example of language in action,
but what makes this language,
both of them are able to speak to and understand each other using their mouse
ears and brains.
That ability gets called language and it's at the heart of a ton of things worth
learning about humans, about communication, about science, philosophy,
logic, and much more.
They're using that general ability called language,
but they're also using a specific language.
They're speaking and hearing English,
but we don't think that this language over here,
English is the same thing as this ability to speak and understand over here.
After all,
they could be speaking French or Swahili and still be using language.
So what is it that sets language apart from all these languages?
The characteristics of our human language ability or the subject of intense
debates. And here's some of the questions that get the brawl started,
is our ability to speak something we learned or something we inherited.
Does it fit snugly in a wider context alongside body signals, emotions,
or other social behaviors and even animal communication?
Or does human language sit way up here all distinct and elevated? Like,
and how does language relate to thinking like the kind of everyday thinking we
do and we have a specific thought, like those flowers are really,
really red.
And also the abstract thinking we do in the logic and mathematics,
logic and math allow us humans to think about things more abstractly and
universally instead of just those roses.
I can think about all roses or all xs,
or even just the variable x.
So it looks like language is a tricky concept,
but what about languages? Surely they're clearer at least.
Okay.
[inaudible].